one common kind of mental illness
which doesn't present itself as an
illness to us of course
it's far too clever for that leads us to
worry incessantly about the future
to worry about bankruptcy disgrace
physical collapse
abandonment what is pernicious about
this kind of worrying
is that it picks up on genuine features
of the here and now
it presents itself as reasonable but on
closer examination
it clearly isn't there are always a few
alarming things going on
there is some turbulence in the economy
there can be things that go wrong with
bodies
reputations do rise and fall but what
should eventually alert us to the
peculiarity of our position
is the duration scale and repetitiveness
of our worries
we should learn to see that we are
essentially worried all the time
about something the target may shift
but what is constant is our insecurity
about existence
it is in such situations that a
therapist may make a hugely useful
intervention
they may point out that the way we worry
about the future
is in fact telling us a huge amount
about our past
more specifically we are worried right
now in a way that mirrors the panic we
once felt as children
we are greeting the challenges of the
adult world with the defenseless panic
of the child we once were
what we are doing in the process is
exchanging the pain of remembering the
difficult past
for a sense of foreboding around the
future the catastrophe we fear is going
to happen
has already happened so sealed off are
our memories
we project them forward where they greet
us as apprehensions of what is to come
rather than identifying themselves as
legacies of the unmasterable past
anxiety
the good therapist becomes aware of the
correct source of the anxiety
and doesn't let go of their insight they
will listen politely and generously to
our description of our current panic
what will happen in our job have we
studied enough
what if our enemies gang up on us but
then they will gently try to shift the
conversation to the past
to show us that the future looks so
fearful because we are being
counterproductively loyal to the terrors
of an earlier age
which we now need to remember to feel
sad about
and then eventually to mourn and move on
from
we should be disloyal to those who
brought us up in an atmosphere of fear
in order to save what remains of life
from always appearing doom laden
we may be trying to stay close to them
by continuing to panic alongside them
but we owe it to ourselves to break the
cycle of worry
and to make our future different from
the past by remembering
localizing and mourning what belonged to
yesterday
even as it pretends to be about tomorrow
how to overcome your childhood is a book
that teaches us how character is
developed
the concept of emotional inheritance the
formation of our concepts of being good
or bad
and the impact of parental styles of
love on the way we choose adult partners